In summary, we had four different major blocks of techniques.
>> You start with the data set or the question that inspires you.
You try to extract the information from it, in the form of, of features.
You feed those features into a machine learning algorithm,
this is the heart of machine learning.
And then you evaluate that entire process to see how good you've done.
One of the hardest things is actually coming with the data set or
the question that interests you.
So one example that I loved was the Enron data set.
For you, this will be something different.
>> We spent a lot of time in class on features, how to present features, how to
get rid of features, how to find new feature spaces that actually work better,
and you can apply these techniques to pretty much any data set to get
really reasonable feature sets.
The heart and soul of this class were the algorithms which is
where the most fun is in machine learning.
You know that they are supervised if you have labels,
unsupervised if you don't have labels.
There are actually more classes in machine learning that you can talk about, but
for the sake of this class, this is what we taught you.
And really important is each algorithm needs to be tuned.
We talked about quite a bit how to tune your algorithms.
>> Last but not least will be the evaluation.
How well are you doing?
There's different types of evaluation metrics that you can use.
Depends on, depending on what's most important to you.
And at this point, once you've worked your way through from beginning to end,
the evaluation metric will tell you if you want to go back and
revisit any of these steps.
Or if you're happy with your results and you're ready to move on.
>> And the cool thing is this is the entire class on one slide.
Isn't that amazing?